joining us is Kareem abdul-jabbar the
hall-of-famer six-time NBA champion he's
got a new book coach wooden and me our
50-year friendship on and off the court
now available online wherever books are
sold
it's good to see again there Kareem how
you feeling I'm doing all right thank
you how famous were you in high school
nationally I actually was famous
nationally although I didn't know it
because I hadn't been all over the
country but scholastic magazine did an
article on me when I was a freshman or
sophomore and everybody every school
like they got scholastic magazine knew
about me unbeknownst to me but imagine
now if you were you'd be on the cover
Sports Illustrated right if you're in
high school no yeah yeah probably I fall
I was in Life magazine as a high school
athlete but did would life be different
though growing up with a spotlight on
you at an earlier age absolutely
nationally but I I started dealing with
that he's my junior in high school how
did your parents help you with that um
they they just ignored it and told me
you got to go to go to high school and
get good grades that that's how they
dealt with it they just said you know
all that that may represent something
but you know who knows that it's going
to bear any fruit so go to high school
get an education and that's what I was
all about that's why I went to UCLA to
graduate but when you make that
transition from famous high school
player to then you go to UCLA they're
defending champs now I know you can't
play as a freshman but just does the
transition work there from being famous
to go to UCLA where you're going to be
on the Freshman team not even playing
varsity basketball well actually for me
it went okay because we played the
varsity freshman game varsity is the
defending national champs we beat them
so now they are number one in the
country but number two on campus that
that
created a situation there and it just
got it just grew from there but when you
had coach wooden dealing with and a lot
of his star players were six eight and
under and now he gets a big man you were
the first legitimate big man that he had
yeah how was different how was he
different or how did you perceive that
of him coaching a big man as opposed to
lot young smaller guys well I had no
experience of em coaching smaller guys
so my experience with him was you know
from day one so it I had nothing to
compare it with so it was just how he
dealt with me that's all I understood
but when did you know that there was
some kind of synchronicity between you
two
oh just actually I realized it while I
was still in high school the way that
UCLA played and the way that I noticed
the Boston Celtics played the two best
teams in the country in their respective
genres I saw the similarities and
realized that the coach wouldn't team
really played the game the right way and
I wanted to I want to learn from him
there's so many things in this book and
even if you think you know everything
about UCLA and you know everything about
Kareem you don't because you bring out
some things and they're not great
moments for Coach wooden that they're
moments where he was very feisty as a
coach in high school got into a couple
of fights I believe I mean you wouldn't
think coach wooden would get into a
fight where he's punching somebody you
know you would and you know saying rude
and solving usually so that wasn't the
coach that I knew but he had had times
like that and there was other stuff
about him that keeps all right he played
professional basketball for about five
or six years for a grocer in
Indianapolis Kowski did the cap ski team
there's a good team so they played a
game in Chicago against the
Globetrotters after the game coach
wouldn't City he usually went home but
he said he had to stay that night
because the food was great and was Cab
Calloway band playing at the Chicago
Savoy that night
so he and Nell stayed and you know so
you know I know Coach wooden as a
church-going man very tightly wrapped
and to think of him on the southside of
Chicago with a lot of black people born
hidey-hole with a cappella that does not
compute in terms of my images of Coach
wooden but he did that when you loved to
have a picture of him I wish I could've
seen that man well I wish I could have
seen Cab Calloway too but you know to to
to know that coach wouldn't had that
experience really it blew my mind cause
that was not you know what I what I
thought about him what was your first
concert my first music concert yeah my
dad took me to see Duke Ellington at
Lewis on Stadium CCC and my I was 7 or 8
years old did you understand that
because I know you write in the book
about Count Basie that your dad missed
an audition right it'll count basic and
my dad took me to see Duke Ellington I
was in seven or eight years I blew me
away to see that band any point in
pointing out the cat Anderson and oh you
know Lawrence Brown and Johnny Hodges
Wow they were heroes of mine and you
know I got this input when I was still
you know seven and eight years old I
grew up loving dance but there was a
jazz like quality to your style on the
court
Yeah right I mean did you did you see I
mean it was that I imagined myself being
Sonny Rollins or John Coltrane or you
know some of the people that I admired
just coasted music went through my head
when I'm explaining would you have one
or two of trade places
oh yeah the cold trainer oh definit on
ker
I wish I could have played bass yeah are
you musically inclined I
I probably was but I wouldn't practice
the piano I wanted to play baseball I
was a big baseball fan right so Dodgers
I want to play for the Dodgers
I pitched in a little league and for my
great school team I got to high school
the basketball coach was also the
baseball coach he sitting in one pinch
he can come on up but I had had enough I
played a ball freshman ball varsity ball
I'm gonna stick to basketball and I just
started concentrating on it at that
point
you ever wonder if you'd stayed with
baseball I needed to have Randy Johnson
as a role model
look like is going hard if I just didn't
know where he played the championship
game you literally got um I'm like
pissed off because we're losing by eight
runs they say you got it all right
you're gonna relieve relieve our
starting pitcher done to me so I go up
there and I'm so angry and everything
I'm going told my best fastball and I
wind up and the ball went up into the
stage and nearly killed somebody you
know so it's good that I didn't fit you
know it's good that that worked out that
well you knew what you were doing with
the skyhook you just didn't know what
you're doing with your fastball the fact
I know what I want I wanted to be Don
Newcombe or Don Drysdale but you know
hey I didn't get that for but never a
Yankee fan never not ever no more that
wasn't allowed in your house no Jackie
Robinson the Duke boy Campanella Carl
Erskine come on me that was my team and
did you get to see Jackie play yeah in
epithelial how was that it was awesome
and I know that I had to watch him he
they walked him I remember they walked
him and instead of watching the pitcher
in the batter I watched Jackie and he
stole second I remember seeing him going
any like disappeared in a cloud I was
like wow that was awesome and you know
that's the only time I saw him do that
but I got to see that did you meet him I
met him I won Rookie of the Year and
they had the award dinner at mama
Leone's okay Marva Kiara smokey the year
so I'm sitting there at the table with
Bill Russell and Jack walks right up to
the table and says hi and I guess I mean
but you're sitting with Bill Russell
yeah I'm talking with Bill cuz I'd met
bill while I was still in high school
and Bill and Jackie were friends and and
Bill had already retired I think Jackie
died in 72 yeah so you were rookie in 71
70 70 yeah okay and then what about
Cassius Clay first time you met him
first huh first time I met him I was a
sophomore a freshman at UCLA
I'd seen him about a week before he was
doing magic tricks on how
Boulevard for strangers just passing by
and do people know it was Cassius Clay
magic tree now I know and I saw him and
I'm like hey like this it's phenomenally
and we've watched him for about 15
minutes mean a couple friends line then
we went on and then just a couple weeks
later I met him at a party did his
religious experience or journey have any
impact on you no didn't I I thought that
the black Muslims were I just turned the
racism that it made my life miserable
they just turned it on its head and
directed it back at white people I
didn't see that making any sense it
wasn't something I wanted to believe in
and you talk about in the book when you
were with the Bucks when your house
burned down when there were murders in
your house you weren't there at the time
the impact that that had on you was
coach wouldn't a sounding board for you
I know he tried to get a hold of you I
think at that time and you weren't
calling him back I didn't call him back
it was a really bad time it was tough
time for me I was trying to make a
decision whether to stay with this
community and realized that the guide
leading it wasn't all the way there you
know he was starting to have you
starting to break down there's so many
other things in this book you know coach
grows up in a place a small town in
Indiana Indiana where is that the home
of the Ku Klux Klan in Indiana southern
Indiana southern Indiana yeah was that
discussed with you and coach coach
mentioned it he said you know the Klan
was big in Indiana when he was growing
up but his dad directed him away from
him told him not to associate with those
people how important was the discussion
of race with you and coach wooden
because it was very important and I
talked about an incident in there where
some woman asked coach I'm standing
there with coach in a restaurant we just
had dinner and some woman comes up to
coach in ask asked him how to how tall
is that and a coach was like devastated
you're sitting there with coach I'm
standing I wouldn't win and he was
talking and she saw that we were all
together so the woman went up to him and
asked asked him that question and he was
devastated and he didn't even know how
to respond he
he never realized that black people had
to go to that and he didn't know what to
say you know on the way home he tried to
talk to me about it and tell me that
ignorant people should not define my
definition of white people you know that
that's what he wanted me to understand
so I understood where he was coming from
but it it really enabled him to see what
a black person goes through that he had
never seen before in his life and it
shocked him and it made him realize a
few things
do you understand Adam Jones the Orioles
when he talked about the racism at
Fenway remind me Kirby Pucket it's the
same thing every pocket said he didn't
want to play in Boston because of
experiences that he had had playing the
outfield there did you have issues in
the garden no I never heard any racial
things in the garden ever oh but I did
listen to Bill Russell when he talked
about how they people came into his home
and vandalized his home he's how many
chain Boston in Boston yeah why did they
hate Bill what did he do I mean did Bill
ever did he understand any of this or
how do you process that I think Bill
understood it insofar as Bill was raised
in Louisiana
okay so Bill understood that Jim Crow
racism is practiced by white people in
America
you never know why but some people
embrace it and Bill had had that
experience I remember reading his book
about his experience with the red are
backin he said his family moved from
Louisiana to Oakland and his mom took
him to the library and it was the first
time he had been to a library and she
said bill he's gonna be spending a lot
of time here you better know where this
building is he'd never been to a library
before I mean that's what life was like
in Louisiana for black people
his dad tried to buy the wood so that
they could build a school for black kids
and when the guy who owned the lumber
mill found out what it was about he
tried to refuse sale of the wood to Bill
Russell dead the Russell's dead got his
shotgun and said look you're going to
give me my money back or the lumber or
I'm going to shoot you right here with
this shotgun and the guy gave gave up
the lumber and want to build dad to get
lost but that's what black Americans
that's a common experience for black
Americans that most white Americans
don't get because they don't experience
it and it's hard for them to believe
that America could be that way I just
remember that press conference where the
famous athletes were there and you were
there and Bill Russell was there and Jim
Brown was there Muhammad Ali was there
yeah sumit and and how young were you at
the time I was 19 I mean can you imagine
I mean how much did you get criticism
for that for being not really and I was
glad I went I had watched the civil
rights movement unfold on on TV I was
trying to understand why black Americans
were hated in America so I've watched
the news every night as the civil rights
movement unfolded and you know I still
hadn't gotten it but I was hoping 14
will come back the book and I highly
recommend it it's it's just such a great
read coach wooden me the 50-year
friendship on and off the court with
Kareem abdul-jabbar Kareem abdul-jabbar
Kahn enough to stay with us for a few
more minutes his new book is coach
wooden and me our 50-year friendship on
and off the court now available online
weber books are sold we were talking
about the summit as you said with the
Jim Brown and Bill Russell and Muhammad
Ali and their yards a nineteen-year-old
let's fast-forward to Colin Kaepernick
in what he did this past NFL season what
did you think when you first heard about
it or saw it when he's taking a knee
well when Colin first started he had a
kind of a hostile attitude about his
demonstrations and people noticed it and
the 49ers were concerned because it was
turning some of their fanbase off I
think so you know fortunately dr. Harry
Edwards works with the 49ers and I think
they were able to get Colin to have his
protest in a way that didn't alienate
people because if you just express your
anger
that's all people are going to react to
but if you couldn't express your concern
and do it in a way that you can
communicate some progress can be made
so I think Colin finally got it together
I understand now that nobody wants to
hire him it seems but I think Colin did
a good job I people start to understand
what he was talking about and that he
wasn't angry at everybody but he wanted
to bring attention to this issue because
it meant something to him it was a
seminal moment for me I think it was
January 20th 1968 and it was the game of
the century and I remember being a huge
UCLA fan and you were you had scratch
retina
I believe scratched cornea marnya yeah
two weeks before and against Cal
scratched my cornea and I expected about
a week or ten days in the NHL Stein eye
clinic at UCLA and then Houston upset
you with Elvin Hayes and I was
devastated I was crushed I don't know
how you felt but were you devastated and
crushed like I was uh I understood why
we lost and I thought that we still were
the better team and I knew that if we
got a chance to play them again it would
be a different outcome and it was 101 69
I believe it yes final in the NCAA
tournament was it better for college
basketball the UCLA law second I think
so i buy that time when we lost to
Houston
you see I had won three of four NCAA
tournament and for everybody to see us
lose made everybody feel good that one
team wasn't going to dominate it but
then we turned that on its head but is
it good to have a dominant team
sometimes dynasty I think sometimes like
I said that brings attention to what
what they achieved and it gets people
excited to see it stopped there was also
a moment in the book you talk about
going up to Schenectady to play against
Pat Riley's team yes so as a freshman I
was in the ninth grade and Ryles is in
my grade he's a senior and so you had a
glaze against Linton high school okay
and what do you remember about that game
they called me out in the first half
I'm 14 years old
a day problem you bid five pounds I
didn't commit I I got fouled at least 20
times yeah I committed five files but
you know they got filed a lot more than
the files I committed but they didn't
call those selves they just called fouls
on the team from New York because they
had this tolki and playing center
I also look at the big man and it always
feels like the big man never gives
everything he's supposed to or were
somehow dissatisfied with the big man's
career except for Bill Russell we're not
satisfied with shacks were not satisfied
with for some reason they might find
fault well you should have one more
right you get that that no no I don't
get that but they they kind of I think
what it is is being long is an advantage
on the court so people admire guys like
Michael Jordan and LeBron who can
overcome their relative lack of height
and still get stucked on that that's
incredible it's spectacular and people
are attracted to that type of athletic
talent but tall people dominate this
game still how would you be now when
you're not allowed to put your you know
body on people and you know back then
they I love that it rough you up a
little bit in the paint I just have a a
day in the paint you know I score a lot
of points I I think that giving a team a
scoring option in the paint that's
reliable
I shot 56% lifetime so getting the ball
to be in the paint was a good idea
easier for somebody to get 80 points in
a game that handles the ball as opposed
to somebody in the paint well all
depends don't like the coach sit could
you not know hundred like wilted i I
think like wilted because the who's that
Alex Hannum was coaching me he told me
every time down throw the ball the will
um I played with guys that needed to get
to ball so you know I didn't want them
thinking that if they threw me the ball
they wouldn't get it back you know if I
if I got double team I I gave it up and
I tried to play a team game and I think
that enabled people didn't resent the
fact that the coaches wanted me to shoot
those high percentage shots because when
defense sag
I passed the ball and the guys got shots
on the perimeter we had a balanced
attack but that goes back to coach
wooden where you're playing on it on a
good UCLA team you had really good
shooting guards and lucious and Mike
Warren and Glenn Shackleford out of the
corner sander but you you understood the
team concept and how important was Plus
you got to be around this for four years
then you go into the NBA if you did a
one-and-done now but no I got to watch
Bill Russell for four years while I was
in high school going to Madison Square
Garden anytime they played a
doubleheader if I didn't have to have to
play that night I was there and I
watched him and learn for me what was it
about Russell though that so the Knicks
weren't your team no no I think oh my
all right I can move for Ray Felix or
Walter to magician
okay I go we'll go Phil Russell oh my
god did you root for will not really
I like Bill we'll used to frustrate I
rather build used to frustrate will I
thought that was great
that was all in his head okay yes doc
gamesmanship and it reminded me of
Muhammad Ali how he did that to George
Foreman no to a Sonny Liston you know
had listened chasing him around me I
knew it that Ali was going to win
because he had messed up listens mine
and listen was chasing him trying to
catch him and punch him in the mouth I
knew that I li was going to win that
fight do you care where you're ranked
all-time no okay
I made my money I got my fans people
understand what I did and if they don't
appreciate it it's okay it feels like
you're underrated
I am underrated but that's okay are you
the best big man of all time possibly
I'm not the most successful Bill Russell
was the most successful and he
understood how to make his team when
eleven World Championships in 13 years
beat that Michael Jordan LeBron is not
going to come close come on are you
better than Jordan I'm not better than
him but I was at least as effective as
he was and I think the effect that you
have on the game is how you should be
judged Bill Russell affected games you
couldn't get a shot in the other Bass
you know he terrorized everybody but for
13 years I when I was training Andrew
Bynum I told him look just go is on eat
on Facebook watch Bill Russell block art
that's all you have to know about how to
play defense just watch that a couple of
times and Andrew started to get it but
he didn't stick with it he was more
interested in he didn't love it he know
he wanted to take the engines out of
cars yeah you're not gonna be a great
basketball player on it and and that's
how it worked out but um but that's what
I tried to do I'll leave you with this
how would coach wouldn't have reacted if
he were still alive and you wrote this
um he would have been happy I don't know
if he would have been happy about me
telling about some of his dark side
moments but he didn't have a lot of them
and you know he overcame it and in such
wonderful ways he should be proud of
what he overcame and there was a moment
if you look on the back of the book it's
you and coach and you're helping him
yeah and I don't know how much longer
did coach live after this do you know
kareem dis pick up about four or five
years oh it was four or five so he's
very frail here yeah here and then
that's why he came to he didn't want you
know people would come up to him for
autographs yeah and he just wanted me to
you know keep her that at a distance
that I didn't knock him down it's a
great picture yeah it is and you know I
saw a picture of that same scene from
behind oh yes when I started crying yeah
because I'm following him yeah you're
leading him yeah he led you he led me no
no I'm leading him so it's a great book
it's a it's not just basketball folks
it's stories and it's it's lessons it's
its life's lessons it's about how to
treat the people that you care about and
that you want to support and how to
accept their love and support coach
wouldn't in me our 50-year friendship on
and off the court Kareem abdul-jabbar
we're back with more after this Thank
You Kareem pleasure Tunku Dan the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you